we specialize in creating artificially
generated content that looks and feels
exactly like reality so we take kind of
real world data we train these neural
Nets and it can more accurately than VFX
or CGI really create this content but
looks and feels so natural well I'm
going to challenge you and your team to
do a bit of a first yeah I mean there's
video of you right up on that screen
show us something surprising you
couldn't oh
wait so there we go this is um you know
a live real-time model of Chris on top
of me
um running in real time I'm so
uncomfortable with this
I am so uncomfortable Can it can it do
voice as well
um um we we think the can we're we're
really pushing we're really pushing a
limit so the AI technology now how do
you feel about the downside of this
technology so personally you know we
build this stuff and I'm worried right
worried is the right Instinct for
everybody to have as individuals it's
going to be kind of difficult to
understand what's computer generated and
what's real and so there are things that
we can do there raising public awareness
of manipulated a media that's one that's
you know this is a great forum for that
will you claim to me that
if you were to shut down your company
right now it wouldn't stop the problem
of deep fake videos because the
Technology's out there that that's going
to happen anyway that that's not within
your control yes there are
we're talking about content that is so
compelling if you know we put any of
ourselves inside content and maybe it is
talking to our loved ones or just
talking to our friends on the beach and
it's so realistic if it looks real it's
so compelling everybody is trying to
create this content today all of the
gpus in the universe are driving at
trying to create this so it doesn't
matter what any one person does this
will happen and it's happening very very
quickly we are going to have to get used
to a world
where we and our children will no longer
be able to trust the evidence of our
eyes
I think so
um we're going to have to understand a
new set of Institutions to verify what
is authentic media but then we can begin
to lead into some of the creative things
that happen from it and there are
benefits that come with that too